educar a pesar del miedo
tras la llegada de los talibanes al
poder un grupo de maestras desafían las
disposiciones del islamismo impartiendo
clases en un pequeño cuarto
acondicionado para ejercer el magisterio
es como matt soy maestra de escuela pero
ahora tras la llegada de los talibanes
las escuelas para niñas están cerradas
por lo que no podemos ir a la escuela y
enseñar a nuestras alumnas como nuestras
alumnas deben estudiar creamos este
pequeño curso en casa así los
estudiantes pueden venir aquí a
escondidas de estudios can can help
haiti tanto alumnos como profesores se
arriesgan en medio de las amenazas
tenemos mucho miedo de los talibanes en
esta escuela en casa pero venimos a
escondidas a diferentes horas del día a
veces por la mañana otras por la tarde
por lo que los talibanes no saben que
seguimos viniendo para enseñar a estas
estudiantes no los voy a ver y cambiarán
teach the students el comportamiento
rebelde de estas instructoras resalta
que la única manera de ser libres en
afganistán es a través del conocimiento
evitando que niñas y adolescentes que
ven inmersas en el oscurantismo
aunque los líderes talibanes afirman que
nunca prohibieron la asistencia a los
colegios son conocidas las trabas
impuestas a la educación en el anterior
régimen islámico del año 1996 al 2001
las niñas esperaron un quinquenio para
volver a las aulas a pesar de las
promesas de quienes ostentaban el poder